is amazing
no one in Israeli politics divides the
country more than Benjamin Netanyahu his
supporters love him as much as his
opponents loathe him
[Applause]
he's on the campaign Trail trying to win
back the job of prime minister that it
held for a total of 15 years until last
year once again it's about Netanyahu for
and against and it's not only a personal
issue it's an issue that have to do with
the
characteristic of Israeli democracy more
majoritarian democracy versus more
populist uh more majoritarian and
populist or more liberal democracy and
of course about identity
right wing left wing the political
stalemate this is the fifth election in
four years is for many Israelis tied to
the start of when Netanyahu was indicted
for breach of trust fraud and accepting
bribes
he says the trials are a political Witch
Hunt polls suggests netanyahu's party
will be the single biggest in Parliament
but just a seat or two short of a
majority he needs every vote I ask you
to go to all of your friends all of your
neighbors and all of your relatives and
tell them that nobody stays home we are
going full power this time full power
with all of our masses to get yair lapid
out of the prime minister's office
to his support as he gave Israel 10
uninterrupted years of economic growth
normalized relations with four Arab
countries and got the U.S to withdraw
from the Iran nuclear Pact
party they could can imagine no other
leader because he's been the leader of
the could for so long he's really shaped
the Party In His Image and the party as
well believes with good reason I think
that they would do less well with
somebody else at the helm you know how
it is in politics if if you feel that
you're party leader is actually reducing
your chances of getting elected you'll
ditch him right away that's not the
sense in the good
his critics say he's threatening
Israel's democracy in his determination
to stop his criminal trials
Netanyahu has suggested he'll build a
coalition with the far-right religious
zionists to form a government the
far-right wants to make changes to the
law that could allow Benjamin Netanyahu
to stall or end the fraud and bribery
trials he's facing but not everyone on
the right is comfortable with sharing
power in Parliament with extreme
nationalists so even if it comes off it
could be a short-lived Coalition forcing
Israelis back to the polls again early
next year
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera West Jerusalem
let's not bring in Stephanie Decker
she's joining us from West Jerusalem so
how much appetite is there for this
election this time around Stephanie
while people are tired I think that's no
secrets you heard there from Bernard
it's the fifth election and three and a
half years so turnout is going to be key
uh of course uh also particularly from
what we're understanding when it comes
to the polls the palestinian-israeli
population could you know if they turn
out in higher numbers than expected than
has been putting that could have
um you know an impact on the final
outcome on the polls certainly from at
the moment it's neck and neck when it
comes to the two blocks very difficult
to call yes likud as Bernard mentioned
there is the party that will looks like
it will have the most seats a couple of
seats ahead of yashatid the party of the
current caretaker prime minister yelapid
but of course when it comes down to
politics here it's all about Coalition
building it's all about getting a
majority in Parliament and when we talk
about a majority these days it's a minor
majority it's 61 seats out of 120 that
are needed and that's pretty much more
or less if anyone gets that majority
vote
um that's going to be the numbers so
it's still going to be very fractious
but again very early days just gone 7
A.M in the morning here in Jerusalem
across the country the polls have opened
a trickle of people here in this Ultra
Orthodox area are coming to vote so
we're going to have to wait and see
throughout the day how the turnout goes
but certainly people do know that this
is a significant election in the terms
of the makeup of who could potentially
come into government right and Stephanie
you were mentioning a moments ago the uh
that the Palestinian is really a voter
turnout could be key but let me ask you
in the lead up to this election to what
extent has the occupation actually been
an issue in this election cycle
when it comes to Israeli elections those
issues aren't really at the Forefront at
the Forefront is always security this is
something that always gets played very
highly
um by all sides also cost of living
there's been a soaring increase in the
cost of living across the country which
is something that Israelis are concerned
about the economy things like that so no
you don't really have that as a major
talking point as a concern for Israelis
across the country it's not on the
agenda you do see however a potential if
you do see Benjamin Netanyahu and likud
and his right wing block come to power
uh one of the phenomenons of this
election has been itamar bengavir this
is a far right-wing politician extremely
controversial even by right-wing
standards um someone who's called for
the expulsion of Palestinians those that
he calls terrorists he's brandished a
gun in occupies Jerusalem calling for
the police to open fire on Palestinians
he's called for the right to Jewish
prayer on the Alexa mosque compound
something that is hugely inflammatory
and provocative to Palestinians so if
you see just to give you a context uh
Benjamin netanyahu's block come to power
it's if you will see someone like Ben
Giver get a major role in the cabinet
and that is something that many Israelis
are saying is a threat to their liberal
democracy and certainly is concerning
um for any future moving forward so
again everything up in the air but uh no
when it comes to sort of the occupation
that's not something that's really on
israeli's Minds when they come to vote
here thank you so much Stephanie Decker
reporting from West Jerusalem